let's talk about power book two okay
uh ghost you're a lawyer there's a
lawyer in this
and and you were reluctant at first when
you found out the role was a lawyer
you weren't sure is that right well not
exactly reluctant not exactly
apprehensive
i was taken aback for a second yeah it
was more because you know i'm here in
power and you know i'm a
fan of the show and most of the show in
my
eyes is like you know where i would fit
in
dust the guns off go out there smack
somebody around extort money
but the agent told me no no this is the
spin-off and they want you to be a
lawyer so i thought about it
it's like oh yeah yeah i could do that i
prepared all my life for this i could be
a lawyer
not a problem whatsoever but um i
auditioned and i
um i got the part the the funny thing is
uh
prior to this years before this during
my acting classes uh
i had to reenact the scene from
philadelphia
and i played the denzel park my scene
partner played the tom hanks part so it
kind of prepared me
for this that's true yeah i mean i would
think to be no better teacher than to
watch
denzel you know playing a lawyer and
and okay this is going to help you you
can you can maybe access some of that
for this role
94 of hollywood has learned or taken
from denzel washington fight me that's a
fact
fight me if you disagree i will fight
you you know what i wasn't gonna fight
you
if you weren't on staten island right
now i would fight you that's the only
thing saving your ass at this point oh
okay all right well i'm just
thank god you're not instead
you look legitimately scared and uh and
you should be
because you want a mess look at this i
see it i see it
god look at those two inch pythons
[Laughter]
you are really fun to talk to i i you
know we got to talk more often you know
i think you need more conan in your life
i really don't think you need more
method no let's not say meth in your
life let's say method man
you need one method man in your life you
know me and dion are cool too i love you
i know yeah that's right
that's right you and deon cole are tight
is that right yeah yes sir yes sir i
don't just post anybody on my instagram
i posted them yeah he is hilarious he's
one of my favorite
guys he's absolutely hilarious in a
great spirit and this is why i know that
you guys are comedic
geniuses i mean just to think off the
top of the head sometimes that you do on
your interviews because i watch
you know i i look for a train wreck to
happen brother
and you have yet yet to be on that track
um i got some i got some footage i could
send you from the early 90s
you'd see some train wrecks in there
yeah we all start somewhere
that's right brother let me make sure i
get the word out here uh power book two
ghost premieres this sunday september
6th at nine on stars that's right and
teenage bounty hunters is streaming now
on
netflix you are killing it as an actor
music you're conquering it all what's
next um i don't know
emperor of the world maybe
you know what yes
i say yes i say yes and i can be your
you be the emperor of the world i'll be
like your court jester
you know where the the bells on the hat
and i'll jump around at your feet
you know what i mean then you can you
can lose your patience with me and go
get
get that [ __ ] head out of here and
they'll just oh my gosh you could be my
kamala harris let's just let's say that
you could be my com
camera that's much more than what i
that's much cooler than what i put out
there so yeah i'll take it there we go
hey listen method man uh an honor and a
privilege thank you for making time for
me i really appreciate it
anytime i've always got time to have
some conan in my life
all right let's uh let's do this again
next time in person because we're gonna
get through this virus
and uh and then we'll we'll fight it out
you know and i'll dress up for the
occasion